a few years ago I got a call from the
highest-ranking legal official in the
state of Georgia
the Attorney General that moment was a
wake-up call it was 2013 and the city of
Atlanta was hosting the final four
basketball tournament the AG called to
ask if the company that I work for could
help sponsor billboards that would be
put up around the city as part of an
anti-human trafficking campaign he said
this was important because sex
trafficking spikes with big sporting
events and with conventions and the
billboards would help to raise awareness
now if I'm being honest with you my
first inclination was to politely
decline let's face it there are
thousands of things that corporate
America could get involved in sex
trafficking seemed a little messy a
little bit too difficult something that
it's better left for someone else but
then I started to understand and learn
how big the problem really is and that
it's rampant in my company's hometown I
lived and worked in Atlanta for years I
practice law here and yet I had no idea
that the birthplace of my children is
among the most prevalent cities for sex
trafficking in the u.s. at last report
Atlanta's illegal sex trade has
generated up to 290 million dollars a
year that's more money than the city's
illegal gun and drug trade combined so
we stepped up and we helped with the
billboards but I couldn't help feeling
like it wasn't enough the parent and me
the mother and me needed to do more I
started talking to people about this and
inevitably I was surprised because the
conversation would turn from curiosity
really this happens here to empathy wow
we've got to do something about that
to blame you're not telling me that
every prostitute is a victim are you I
mean don't they know what they're
getting into I get it I understand why
people are confused so to be clear the
people that I'm talking about do not
choose this life they're forced
defrauded or coerced that's actually the
legal definition for human trafficking
under federal law for adults now when it
comes to kids any minor under 18
that's transported facilitated or used
for commercial sex is automatically a
victim regardless of whether force fraud
or coercion is used this crime knows no
age gender or socio-economic barrier I'm
talking about the 16 year old girl that
I met in Washington DC she had been
trafficked from the time she was 14
until she was 16 she was a victim of the
foster care system and she told me she'd
been sold up to five times a day she
didn't even know the term human
trafficking she thought that it was just
a part of her life as a foster care kid
sex trafficking also shows up in
affluent areas and gated communities and
men lure young girls into sex
trafficking situations with promises of
modeling contracts cell phones sometimes
they're just kidnapped right off the
street in the u.s. an estimated 200 to
300 thousand girls and boys are
anticipated to be used for commercial
sex trafficking every year you heard
that right
girls and boys worldwide the
International Labour Organization
estimates that up to 1 million children
a year are vulnerable for sex
trafficking those numbers are huge and
so while the billboards are great for
raising awareness generally they're just
not enough to put it into this problem I
believe that if we're going to be
serious
about sex trafficking we can't legislate
or arrest our way out of modern-day
slavery if we really want to end sex
trafficking in the u.s. we have to
systematically educate and target demand
and I think the business community is in
the perfect position to do just that so
sex trafficking is big business and I'm
proposing a business plan that starts
with the customer and in the sex trade
the customer is referred to as a John he
is the man that fuels the demand for sex
trafficking John's do not fit into neat
stereotypes but there is one universal
truth no John no buyer no victim so if
we want to start to put a dent in sex
trafficking we have to get to John and
businesses can do that while he's at
work there's an organization called
businesses ending slavery and
trafficking or best for short and when
they launched in 2012 they did a study
of seattle-based John's and you know
what they found out
John's our everyday guy's employed at
local businesses they range in age from
18 to 84
John's are dads John's have admitted
that they buy sex when they are
traveling for business when they're
going to sporting events or when they're
in the military but here's the kicker
best study determined that web-based sex
buying spikes at 2:00 p.m. in the
afternoon which means that these John's
are likely buying sex in the middle of
the workday I believe that there's a way
to stop John's in the middle of the
workday from buying sex and businesses
can do it in 3 simple ways the first is
with a policy a policy that clearly says
the company prohibits sex buying during
work with company resources or on
company time that's right I'm saying
that your handbook has to specifically
give an example that says no sex buying
while you're traveling at the
international trade show because that's
where it's happening now a policy is
only as good as its enforcement and it's
communication several studies have
indicated from johns that the best way
to deter them is public humiliation and
embarrassment so businesses who catch
John's buying sex using company based
equipment or company resources but cut
them a break or sweep it under the rug
and don't fire them are complicit and
fueling demand now a policy is one of
the best ways to start the second way is
educating the workforce businesses can
go a long way in simply training their
workforce about the signs and the red
flags of human trafficking this was my
aha moment for how our company could
make a big difference
our nation's highways airports and truck
stops are literally used as modern-day
slave routes our company has more than a
hundred thousand drivers all over the
country all over the world and so it
made perfect sense to train them to see
the red flags we don't want them jumping
out there and doing things on their own
so we want them to call a phone number
the hotline and let law enforcement
intervene so to do this we teamed up
with an organization called truckers
Against Trafficking this colorado-based
organization had web-based support and
materials that we gave to our truck
drivers that gave them exactly what they
needed to spot the red flags like
hearing CB chatter on their radios about
girls at nearby exits or seeing
underaged women emerging from vehicle
in the truck stop parking lots when we
rolled out his training a few brave
drivers admitted they had seen these
women knocking on the cabs in the truck
stops looking for customers now they
said that they weren't buying but they
also didn't know enough to make a call
and that's what we want them to do tax
organization truckers against
trafficking also emphasizes the need for
men to talk to other men about web-based
sex buying and not buying commercial sex
they feature men in uniform proudly
proclaiming why they don't buy if we're
gonna see a cultural shift in this
atrocity we need men talking to other
men about the underlying issues fueling
demand because sometimes johns don't
even know that they're purchasing girls
who are enslaved which brings me to my
final way that businesses can help every
business has a special resource or a
secret sauce or resource that they can
bring to fight human trafficking
for example Visa MasterCard and American
Express refused to process transactions
from backpage.com an online sex site
that sold commercial sex to the tune of
nine million dollars a month in April of
2018 backpage.com and affiliated
websites were shut down and the FBI
seized all their assets hiring a
survivors is another way that any
company can help Randstad an
organization that works with companies
to find survivors who had need good jobs
has an excellent program called higher
hope we've used this program we know
that it works in addition to training
their flight attendants and their
airline crew Delta Airlines also offers
sky miles through a program called sky
wish to survivors to help them escape
their traffickers and reunite with their
families there are thousands of things
that businesses can do they just have to
decide
what to do to join the fight no one can
justify slavery today but I believe it
remains one of the greatest civil rights
atrocities of our time
fortunately the business community is
uniquely positioned to help train their
employees to enforce policies and to
help use their special resources to
fight human trafficking and what about
you what if you decided to learn the red
flags what if you decided to look at the
signs that are all around you and make a
call there is no penalty for calling law
enforcement when you see something that
doesn't sit right together we can all
protect our children we can educate the
workforces around us and improve society
where we all live and work with John
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]